[Musique]
déjà au matin à me dire est que la vie
si tous qu'on est astucieux bell bell
est la furie à jouer et les amis
à la halle à tous quand je suis coincé
là
aïe aïe aïe passe arc ça y'est c'est
bien de temps en temps quand je crie
trop fort ça coince je vais te faire une
confidence
oui je suis effrayé alembon je suis quoi
comme dit tu l'as je suis quoi tu es
quoi je ne sais pas quoi te dire je ne
sais pas quoi faire alors pour faire
c'est très simple nous allons faire de
la géographie ça ça va ça c'est toujours
toujours la géographie c'est bon mais
alors j'ai des absences de mémoire ou
dit c'est possible c'est qu'est ce qui
m'arrive est tu te couches trop tard tu
vas tous les soirs au bal de la forêt je
ne sais plus le lendemain matin j'ai vu
ce que tu fais et l'après midi tu dors
je me rends tu vas dit qu'ouvrir la
carte géographique du pays qui est
derrière le bleu est absolument sableux
et où j'avais le nez rouge à bonta bleu
et rouge oui c'est original
voici donc la carte du pays que nous
avons à découvrir
bon je te signal oui c'est la petite
partie du pays à découvrir
c'est pas la grande partie tu as vu
qu'est ce que tu me racontes
je suis dit que c'est la petite partie
la petite partie oui tu fais ce que tu
veux mais je vois pas bien le rapport la
feria ça c'est un pays ça c'est ça oui
il est bien d'accord c'est là où tu as
ta main c'est par une sous non c'est pas
en dessous ça c'est tout chaud et la
capitale oui j'ai passé parfois là nous
avons le drapeau du pays
et juste pour faire ça quelle couleur il
est et ben écoute
il est rouge ah c'est ça il est rouge et
l'état de l'étoile qui est au centre et
verte 6 1 oui d'ailleurs à la porte un
nom de cette étoile cinétoile spéciale
une étoile oui moi tu vois qu'elle est
un peu particulière boyer et bonjour se
dit salam aleikoum sait rigoler salam
aleikoum jalava y voit la salle après
c'est ce que c'est que ce pays 1
c'est ce que c'est que ce pays odier oui
oui gradins oui on veut s'en va bien ous
avez devinez de quel pays il s'agissait
le maroc en afrique du nord à l'ouest de
l'afrique du nord avec sa capitale rabat
qui n'est pas la plus grande île des
pays mais qui est la capitale le drapeau
l'écriture
d'ailleurs pardon bien si bien situer
absolument c'est au bord de la mer rabat
et l'étoile s'appelle l'étoile
chérifienne
voilà elle est verte sur le drapeau
rouge pourquoi tu me dis ça bakkour tu
le saches tient salam aleikoum un avis à
la gamme salam salam fayyad
alors je le croise avec le point commun
parce qu'il dit 2 on y juste entre nous
la oui oui je vous l'avais pas du rapido
ceux aperçus tout à l'heure dé jeu n'est
pas la tradition
je n'ai pas vu dans son nom alors on
étend la new bond fabrice oui voila
voila mais j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive et
tâchez d'être en pleine forme parce que
croyez moi saddam j'ai bien travaillé
salam sall avait cru bon alors le jeu du
point commun tous cancan belle-baie les
pouces vous sur représente quelque chose
et les avons tous à découvrir quel est
le point qui les unit c'est tout con qui
commence comme d'habitude comme
d'habitude
pourquoi pas je t'écoute alors je vais
t'aider c'est très simple parce que -
j'existe chaque fois que vous voulez
vous rendre à pied d'un endroit à un
autre chose comporte neuf pour aller
cueillir des champignons que ce soit
pour faire le tour de votre petit jardin
avec vos invités ou même pour une
randonnée de plusieurs kilomètres je
suis là et en plus de ça je suis sportif
moi avec mon établi des records 2,10
2,20 de 50 kilomètres et je suis quelque
chose qu'on apprend d'ailleurs
facilement
je me demande si c'est pas la première
chose qu'on apprend dans la vie vous
avez bien une photo de vous qui vous
représente en train de faire vos
premiers pas oui et des barbes à la
suite à ces mois-ci et troy bell bell
alors moi je vous signale que dans la
petite maison qui est la mienne nous
sommes plusieurs de mon espèce c'est une
petite maison à un étage
mais chaque fois que vous montez au
premier pour chercher quelque chose et
chaque fois que vous redescendez vous
vous servez de moi oui je sais que je ne
suis pas très importante mais je vous
conseille de faire très attention à moi
à car je peux être dangereuse je peux
vous faire tout mais parfaitement sur
wii ou si je suis bien entretenues bien
cirées bien en coûte
excuse-moi fabrice oui c'est un mois
c'est difficile à dire
oui ça veut dire bien en course ticket à
d'ailleurs si j'ai un conseil à vous
donner
chers amis c'est de me recouvrir d'un
tep j'adore ça je crois que j'ai trouvé
mais ça aussi at il dit j'ai trouvé
avant même que j'aie flinois je pense
j'ai cependant ses limites
oui ça m'a beaucoup ça va bien tout
cancan s'il te plaît on laisse la laisse
là par les rouges moi je suis maintenant
oui oui alors alors alors moi je moi je
suis beaucoup plus artiste que tout
kankan et belle belle oui moi je suis
musicien à ces sites
j'adore les îles boum-boum tralalère
mais oui je suis de la musique
entraînante
je donne envie aux gens de deux défilés
une baisse d'ailleurs on utilise
beaucoup pour les jours de fête le 14
juillet la fête des pompiers
les kermesses ils viennent tout cela
avec eux leurs casquettes leurs
instruments et et défilent comme on dit
je suis très entraînant on ne me résiste
pas voilà qui est bien mais les enfants
je crois que j'ai trouvé je suis
d'ailleurs ce n'était pas tellement
difficile vous avez remarqué que tout
cancan tout à l'heure nous a parlé d'un
certain nombre de choses assez précise
malgré tout surtout de notre plus tendre
enfance et les premiers pas que nous
faisons c'est parce que nous marchons le
savions de la marche les promenades
puissance de la marque propre de la
course
oui belle belle nous plaît de sa maison
qui est charmante où elle a un escalier
avec de très jolis marche et bonne
marche et enfin toucan pardon pousser
moscou de lui était très entraînants
rica et ça y est c'est bien sûr d'une
marche militaire ivala marché militaire
mais ça reste un bon belle gueule à
propos de musique tu sais ce que tu as à
faire mais bien sûr bon bien sûr cher
petit ami a tout de suite fabrice est
une belle bouche vous suffit de cliquer
alors voyons tu compenses tel reprends
toi que tu es bien c'est à nous pas
prêtes à nous de jouer
tu vas aller au tableau et ben oui nous
allons aller au petit jeu oui notre
petit jeu alors avec tes fautes
d'orthographe non non non non pas cette
semaine donc je le serpent de toi à
cette semaine sur deux toujours de moi
je suis sûr de moi alors tu vas au
tableau n'a pas oublié ton marqueur
regard des travaux très bien alors cette
semaine un petit mot en cette lettre
doit à cette lettre
on commence par et bien on commence par
un e voilà le feu alors 5-2 3,4 un
employé la dernière un thé alors je
t'écoute
allez tiens allons plus près c'est un
animal et ben oui gouin qui est un
animal c'est un petit animal qui coud
est un petit animal qui courent c'est
pas un petit animal
oh la la loi de là pourquoi ni mal il
est gros qu'il est gros il est très
grande et très très très gros il ne vole
pas
or ils ne veulent pas bien que c'est le
plus gros ils ne veulent pas oh non il
vole pas haut non parce qu'alors on
retombera sata du bruit c'est un animal
qui vit en europe
non le lyonna dans les cirques aux fans
ce poignant sage en a dans les cirques
et veux tu veux te donne une lettre
supplémentaire
je veux bien alors la quatrième lettre
c'est un f jeu mais c'est fini rapide au
sein tu n'as pas le droit de souffler
c'est moi qui joue s'il te plaît oui
alors tu me dis af l'arrêt j'avais bar
et le petit rang dessous parce qu on
pourrait confondre voilà voilà
alors un f1 énorme oui avec un et
flammes plusieurs tonnes c'est ça oui je
crois que tu nous a encore réussi une de
ses erreurs d'orthographes hongrie par
terre c'est papa si non tu ne penserait
pas tout de même à l'éléphant mais
gillet les vents qui s'écrit
naturellement celestine001 créé
éléphants éléphants décidément nous
sommes en plein progrès mon cher pouces
monsieur brun et les 100 e l e
nous sommes d'accord mais ensuite ph
s'il te plaît aura t elle été
voilà comment on écrit un éléphant tu ce
exact où mocambos tu te plait je suis
sûr que tu ne le savais pas non plus
rapide au sol si tu peux être une des
zones et mais quand atou comprend bien
entendu lui aussi bas il n'a pas aidé du
tout en tout cas il ya une chose que tu
ne s'est peut-être pas il paraît que
l'éléphant malgré ses grandes oreilles
il n'entend pas très bien ce qui est
plus développée chez lui c'est l'odorat
il faut dire qu'avec année aussi l'oncle
siens c'est c'est un peu normal et une
belle tron à oui c'est fini
eh bien c'est fini alors je m'occupe de
benfeld a maintenant un petit peu de
musique s'il vous serez bell bell
[Musique]
fabre facebook
si la musique tibétains doit pas
abandonner sa lancée cette lettre fait
douter beaucoup la mode tu sais ce qui
t'attend mais oui mais oui je vais te
raconter une histoire dans laquelle
certains mots seront au complet
et toi tu les complétera ces mots par
des notes de musique
les voilà toutes ces notes te donneront
le début de l'ère d'une chanson très
connue donc là si l'histoire bien c'est
une histoire très triste
alors je ne vous raconterai pas jusqu'à
la fin non parce que moi ça me donne
envie de plus l'heure de jeu mais en bas
oui oui c'est l'histoire d'une jeune
fille qui a envie d'aller dans ces tops
ses amis vont ils ne voudraient pas
passer ce soir et en isère en coin
rachel était en ce mois ci needed en
piquant boulot pensa est ce que tu dis
oui alors sa famille trouve qu'elle est
bien jeune cette petite jeune fille et
lui interdit de sortir la pauvre petit
manque de sa chambre se lamente celle à
la peau mais voilà que son frère arrive
ce frère est un garçon un peu
indiscipliné si l'une est l indiscipliné
il dit à sa soeur
viens je t'emmène au cou
il n'a pas besoin de ce fait si la
petite serre a vite pris sa décision
c'est fini rapide aux jeunes ont 6 pas
fait seulement moi j'ai la suite de ma
petite histoire alors elle s'habille
elle se coiffe se met en grand tralala
j'en mets un ou deux eh bien comment tu
en mets cas non non non mais pas dû au
hasard
il aurait il quitte la maison sur la
pointe du coup il longe ans il est
maintenant si tu savais ce qui t'arrive
n'hésite pas rabelais je me suis ado ado
oui enroulé dont we may lose all or
c'est parfait et alors tu ne restes pas
près d'airé sidéré par fédérer alors tu
me relis les natifs et bien nous avons
ré sol la si si si la cites d'aussi
s'équipe d'un bassin si tu perds tu
permets d'y doper pas beaucoup permet de
confiner oui c'est parfois qu'est ce que
c'est que ça a l'air d'aller mieux
alors c'est le pot datation
ali m dames et la daba daba bravo
j'arrive à a tout de suite belles belles
annonces faites dans jonathan qui est à
tapis
déjà papa papa d'amy ces quatre là tu
peux paraître que la vie majeur s'est
désisté et g shock fait des choses mais
comme je n'y pas de minois negro a fait
attention les quatre amis sont
compatissants réussi mais y'a qu'ça me
sens heureux d'arriver
oui
[Musique]
vip a joué aujourd'hui et dit vouloir
devenir amis
[Musique]
jamais tu n'est possible